Now we've gone through all the different sections of the interface,
we'll be ready to do some actual coding
and see about creating and connecting up some nodes.
Now here we are in the event graph,
in the example actor that we've made.
Now, we have three different red nodes.
Each of these represent an event.
What they are is a starting point for when you're going to run some code,
which would be triggered by the engine,
depending on what they are connected to.
So for here we have the event begin play,
the event actor begin overlap, and the event tick.
Now let's work with the event begin play first.
If I was to drag off and add in a print string afterwards,
this is a simple node which is going to print the word
hello when it is fired.
Now if I compile this, jump back into the engine,
I'm going to make sure that we have show stats ticked here,
just so that we can make sure that we can see the messages in the viewport.
Now if I push play, you can see that we have
hello in the top left hand corner here.
Now that's because this script will,
anything that's connected to this script,
will trigger when the actor is either spawned into the world,
or when the the program starts to begin play.
Now I'm going to drag this down and connect it to tick.
I'm going to press compile and jump into the engine again.
Now when I push play, we'll see that we have a long
string of hellos down the left hand side.
Now that's because this tick event will trigger when every frame
of the game. So if you're running at 60 frames per second,
that is going to run 60 times per second.
Now we have one other one that we are going to check out here,
and that is the construction script. Now if I was to do the same thing here,
and compile, you will now see if I grab our actor and move it in the world,
move it in the world,
so these go away, you can see that this will trigger on
all of the movements. So this is great for if you wanted to
randomize an asset when it was placed in, or you wanted to do some kind of
computation looking at the world when it is
placed into the world. That means that the load from the script is
done at construction time, and saved to the actor,
rather than at runtime, when a lot of other things might be firing.
So again what we have here is we have the event begin play. This will be
triggered at one time when it first starts off. We have the
event begin overlap, but we're going to ignore that. We're going to do this in a
different way slightly later on. And we have event tick. Now this
triggers on every single frame of the game
by default, so be very very careful what you place on this.
You can actually control it by coming into the class defaults and changing
the settings for the tick here. You can either
turn it off, or reduce the speed of it. And then
finally we have construction script. Construction script will fire on the
point of construction. So now let's go over
the different ways that you can add nodes to the event graph.
What I'd like to do is go over the three different,
most common ways I think that you'll come across
here in order of least used to most. Now the first way I'd like to
go over is something called the palette. Now if we go up to windows and
select palette in the drop down, this won't be turned on by default,
you'll see that we'll get a window on the right hand side.
And this is going to have two sections. At the top this is going to have your
favorite nodes, and below this
it's going to have a searchable library of all of the different nodes
that you can come across. Now in order to bring these in all
you need to do is select one, hold down the left hand mouse
button, and drag it onto the event graph. You can see here I've
just pulled a branch over. And again I'm going to remove this by
pushing delete. Now this is quite useful and it's good
if you want to search through everything.
However, it tends to be a little slow when we're programming.
The second way to get nodes into the chart
is via the hotkeys. Now there are a few standard hotkeys which
will come default with the engine when it's
installed. You can actually go in and update and
change them yourself, but the default ones are...
Now if you hold down a B you'll get a branch,
if you hold down a D you'll get a delay,
if you hold down S you'll get a sequence,
if you hold down G you'll get a gate, if you hold down an N you'll get a do
N times, and if you hold down O you will get a do once, and for M
you'll get a multi-gate. Now I'll expect you need to know what all of
these would do, but the important thing to understand
with these is they're mostly flow control. So these are mostly
going to allow you to control the method of execution.
Now the most common flow control node you're going to come across
is going to be the branch node, and now if we look at a branch node you'll
see on the left hand side of this we have a red pin. This denotes
a condition that is a boolean condition. Now we'll go over variables in a
second, but a boolean variable is a
zero or a one, and this would denote true or false usually, with zero being
false and one being true. And now you can see
with this flow control we would have an execution pin coming in from the left
here, and then if the condition was set
to true this would trigger anything that was
connected to the true pin. If the condition was set to false
this would trigger whatever was connected to the false pin.
So this is the equivalent of an if statement,
if you would be working within other programming
languages. Our final way of generating
nodes is going to be by right-hand clicking in the background.
And now what you'll see is we have a box
that appears, a search box. Now if I was to search for example
branch you'll see that it will bring up branch.
Now it's also quite smart as well, so if I was to search for if
it will also bring up branch as a selected, and just because it knows that
if you're working in coding, if you type in if, you probably want a branch
statement. And at this point if I was to just
press enter it's going to create it at the point
where the point where I clicked on the screen.
Now this is even more useful than other methods
because if you look in the top right hand corner here
we have a tick box that's called context sensitive.
Now what this means is this is only going to return
values for nodes which would be compatible
with the context you're in. So at the moment this is only going to return
any of the nodes which could be placed on an event graph.
Now if I untick this it's actually going to reconfigure this
and it's going to return every single node which is part of the
system or that you've created or other part of
plugins. And this can be quite useful if
you're searching for something very very specific you might want to
turn this off and then you can do a more thorough search.
However with context sensitive on this is going to help you find the right
nodes that you want to get hold of. So for example if I was to drag
in a cube so this is a reference this is a variable is a
reference to the cube component that I have here. If I was to drop
this it's going to give me an option to
get or set. Now I'm going to get the cube. Now if I was to
hover my mouse over the input pin the output pin for the cube drag off.
Now you can see here actions taking a static mesh component object reference.
So this is going to limit everything that's reported in here to
only things which would take a component a static mesh component as
an input. So if I come in here and I now type in
destroy you will see I get two options I get
destroy component and is component being destroyed.
So if I was to then select destroy component
you'll see it's going to create a node and it's automatically going to link
this up. Now let's compare that to if I right
hand clicked here and I typed in destroy you'll see I get a lot of
different nodes. I get a destroy actor event destroyed
and here is the destroyed component but it's harder to find the appropriate one
that I'm looking for where previously I would just get a
single one and I know that it would connect up.
So this context sensitive is really really useful
in order to to limit what you're seeing to only stuff that you can
actually use. So that way you've got
that is the most common method for for getting hold of nodes and adding them
into adding them into the there is also
something to be said for copying and pasting. Now if I wanted to
if I got nodes like this and I wanted to
copy them and all I need to do is use the standard computer
clipboard. So with these highlighted if I press
ctrl c I can then move to another another place press ctrl v
and you'll see that it's going to create those nodes
just by what is copied there. Now we can also use
our other methods for example if I was to press ctrl f
x I was to press ctrl x it'll take everything
and again if I press ctrl b I can then paste them anywhere.
That's because when you copy and paste these they're saved to the clipboard
as a as a text value. Now
one more option that we have here is with it highlighted if I was to press
ctrl d the duplicate it's going to copy
whatever I have highlighted at that time. That's just a useful
method of doing things. Now let's talk about connecting these up.
So as you can see here I have three branches
I'll say I wanted to connect this up to the event begin play
I can drag off of this execution pin and you'll see as I move the cursor
over the input pin on the branch I get a little green
arrow and that means that if I drop that it's going to allow me
it's going to connect that up. Now what I can do so say for example I
was to do that here now if I wanted if I wanted to
disconnect this and connect it up here I can do that by
floating over either of these pins holding down the alt key and left
clicking and let's go to disconnect. Something
else I can do is if I was to fall back over one of
these keys hold down the ctrl key you'll see that
this changes into a small little hat. If I left click I can now
drag that to reconnect to other locations. So with this video
we know how to bring in move around and connect up
nodes. In the next one we're going to start talking about variables.